RUSSIABEVION, A
THISA RUSSIAN BATTIO CRITICIZIN
WAS PU PLACETTS ALERENT UNITS. I
>> THE ANGER ECHHI BATTALION TDR
LETTER FROM A RUSSIA ON
INDEPEENJOURNALIST
DSIN EMY ISSUNFLO
US
DECEIV.
THERE IS NO TRUTH  TO
E  IMMINENT
WITH THEIRUTING OUT.
WOMISED THAT WE WOULD MORTAR  .
ARMY.D E N ARMY
OFE WAGNN  IS
GROUP ANISBETTER
CONSTANT COMPLOFO AMMUNITI.WAGNO
OUF THEM N
INJURED.
AND TH
FORMER RUSSIAN MILITARY OFFICER
SO, IN FAIRNESS,
WAN DRAG ON FOR RSHALED.DEO TH
N .
>> Reporter: THIS ISTH OVEKS
WAR HALEF KUPIANSK
INAS THAT TH
FRONT LINE NEVEROM.E POLICEBY C
A  AMMUNITIO
AFTER THEY WERE IV O LESS THAN.
YOU HEAR THOSEXPSI SAYS
THE POLICE CHIEF
THOSE ARE ROCKETS FLYING
HESBDESTRONEIGHBOR'S HOUSE A TVU
XPINS AT
NIGHT.
SOOLD
HANDS.
IT KEEPS THESAHOMEE SA
NOT TH
BESIDES,HE SAYS, IT'G
WARMER NOW. THE RAI THEY COLLEC
KUPIANSK WAS ONEE MOST URVIVE.
BUT ATE CO FS CLOSING
EVACUATED TOS AVING KUPI A
ITIGG VILLES
NO KEYS, A THE HLL
CANF AROUND 27,000 NOW  2,500,
BEEN ENTIRELY DESTROYED THATTHI
BEENITTLE QUIETER, WE'REING. PEE
SELLINWHN WHILE THCAN.
>> Translator:
AFRAID.ep
RY, BOTH
G.HERE, SHE
EXPLAINS.
WE'RE NORATS, WE WON'T AON
OUR CI
DO TAKE OVER CIVILIANSF KUPIANS
BY THE SHIFTINWIS
.
WHAT WE'VE BN SEEING SINCE
ABOUT MID-FEBRUARY I
THAT EASTERN F LINPRESSURE ORUN
.
AT BHMUTOF BUT FURT TTHN
DONETSK PROVINCEAY TO
AND IT IS  CE ANS CAUGHT IN THE
FOFI THE, BUT THE IRTIMEHTMESSH
O N R,ANR OF THEOUP.
OBVIOUSLY SO MUCH TO TISK ABOU
THEY ARUITING YMS.
M T  PLA T
IS THIS REALLY GOING TO BE T END
NKIGOZHIN, IT?
CRO'S INIR PUTIN.ES TO A H.>>>>H
HAVE A GOOD RETI WIT
E
IFE  H TALKINGO
RUSSIAN
E'T
AND  C GROUND IN
KIINKIS  I THIS IS
LITERALLDONSMETERSLAND BEIAK
'RHROWING
TENS OF THOUSAND YOUNG
AT TKRAINIANS,OW
I  HASFOMO'S APPALLING TO IME FW
>> IT ISOULDN THENFO
BIA'S ENOE'S AN ARTICN THE
"FINANCIAL TIM A
SAG OUT OF
NET THAT MOR
THANT COMES  FOSSIL FUEL
HE SAYS THEY ARETOINY NDLEINHIVE
E GG THE
FUNDS.NOW, DO YO IS
SAWICLY
CONTRAN OF THE RUSSIAN
ECONOMY LAST YEAR.
XPECTING THA THEY WILLLL
SMALAMNT OGROWTH.
NUSE ARE NBEESE
ARE NOT NUERM ATIONAL ECONOMIST
WANTS.
ECAUSEE EUROPEANS DON'T BUY IT,T
ANYWHERE ELSE.
RECE RUSSIANT
BUE IDEA THAT THITND THE EUROPE
CREDIB AND IER THE ONLY YOU COUO
E TL INGNESS TOTIONS ON, YOU KO
THE CHI
BUYINGUSNE
PUONS ON
DOING THAT.'SHAT.
- WE DON'T HAVE